[Applause]
how did it feel when your daughter moved
out
well drew
in all honesty excitement and i'm sure
every parent when they're going to drop
their kid off at school to live and
learn in a new environment it's exciting
but
the excitement lasts only
i would say a week
and then the reality of it um a lot of
sadness sorrow grief loss
actually followed that feeling of
excitement
and uh you know just recently
we've been looking to
you know kind of like re-establish our
relationship and strengthen and
you know figure out ways to get
connected with intimacy again and tell
me what's the priority for you in this
big shift
um it's funny she came up with a term
called the relationship
right
so which i was like wow that's pretty
clever um
it does shift back to you so like me
personally this year as like an adult
man i had like this instead of a midlife
crisis i what i call a midlife
renaissance where i started to just
figure out like who i am in this space
without being celia's dad right
but there's this part of us that i think
gets lost over 19 years of parenting and
like we're looking for ways to like get
back to that because we were awesome
like in the beginning we're still
awesome we're awesome parents we have a
great relationship we really do
but in the beginning
we were like you know you're like the ed
couple it was really fun and i want to
get that some of that fun back i was
joking stop drop
and roll with it
[Laughter]
stop drop and roll with it that's where
i want to go all right
might need to write a book but before i
get into that because you have a lot of
isms that are really on point and
speaking of on point demona
thoughts advice
prompts
well i'll try i'll try to come up with
some isms myself but in the meantime i
just want to acknowledge everything that
you said and how you're feeling i'm a
parent too and it sounds it sounds great
but i'm sure when you get there the
feelings that come up are are very
different and you have an opportunity
right now to go through this
relationship and rewrite the rules of
romance for yourselves so just doing
little things like creating boundaries
in the home like do you do you have any
rules for the bedroom i'm not talking
about like those kind of rules
do you have rules around like phones in
the bed or computers or dogs
nope
we want all those things out we want to
focus on the two of you because really
the bedroom has two functions it's for
rest
and this was sexy time and so we
we want to reset that that space to be a
place where you two can connect and you
also want to create some some rituals
for yourselves so when you get home from
work
not just going right into the the next
thing and the kind of uh routine that
you've been in but maybe take a walk
together cook dinner have a cocktail do
something that's a regular ritual that
will reset the energy from the workspace
into the romance space i also noticed
that you guys liked going out dancing
when you were younger you were like at
webster hall your favorite like 90s
house music
okay i am feeling my little pleasure
that was me too
and i'm so mad at society
[Applause]
we have got to like i i see you guys at
webster hall where you used to like go
and dance and get sweaty i'm like the
bedroom try the living room couch
throw that rule book out the window
i also uh liked the fact that you both
had things that occupy you
philanthropically
and you know used to do that like maybe
try doing it separately so that you have
something to come back and talk about
one of my biggest things is also like
meet there
don't do the obligatory i say this every
time demona it's like i want to tattoo
it on my body meet there
don't do they were getting ready the
drive you're out of conversation by the
time you got there
so spending time apart yeah doing things
like outside of each other
especially with your interests and
hobbies and
do them apart so that you are like out
there and you're like i have this rad
husband i get to get home to and like
talk to all of this about
anything to look forward to well demona
has a really interesting tradition that
she does that i am madly in love with um
demona will you tell
about what you asked of tommy and tracy
please well i'd love to do nostalgia
dates with my clients and have them do
things that they used to do
or go through memories that they had
together to reignite some of those
feelings again when you re-experience
the memory it actually brings back all
of those same emotions that you once
felt and i know you were you were hot on
the town before and things were spicy
and sexy and so i asked them to bring in
a photo of a time in the past that each
of them really could connect to and
remember those feelings again so i'd
love to take a look at the pictures that
they brought in
okay whose photo was this that was
that was my picture
why why are you reacting because that
was my picture
[Applause]
the same image
that has never happened before really
that's really amazing and it really just
shows the bond between the two of you
you have you share these memories
together and you built these moments and
the life that you have together so this
is just a reminder that you have all the
elements you have the foundation and
just with a little bit of of tweet a few
tweaks and with a little bit of focus on
really building that bond again you two
are gonna be just fine
[Music]
you